[Music]
it's time for et's social study a quick
look at what your favorite celebs are
sharing online Kobe Bryant and wife
Vanessa welcomed baby number three
earlier this month and finally shared
the first photo of their daughter Bianca
via Instagram Wednesday in a sweet
slumber I'm excited demi lovato is in
the holiday spirit belting out her
rendition of a Christmas classic song
silent night
[Music]
[Music]
round young virgin meanwhile mother
Monster is celebrating a special
occasion in her life getting inked for
the 20th time
lady gaga got a new tat that red Haws
right above her mouse tattoo in honor of
her sister Natalie paying tribute to the
creative team responsible for her unique
style over the years I'm just so pleased
very very lucky girl this year to have
people really believe in me and Sofia
vegara son is following in his famous
mother's footsteps
Finola Vergara made his modeling debut
in paper magazine looking dapper in a
classic suit and tie well it's clear the
apple doesn't fall too far from the tree
here's Sofia fiercely posing as a model
in this 80s throwback degree thank you
check out John Legend showing off his
sexy physique while doing some handiwork
at home Chrissy Teigen documented her
hubby building a popcorn machine on
snapchat Wednesday and he's all muscle
[Music]
you